ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
chairman of the munich security
conference ambassador wolfgang ishinger
[Applause]
good morning
everyone
good morning
to the second day
of a very very unusual munich security
conference
my team and i are extremely proud that
we've been able to
organize this physical event
which so many of you have wanted
to participate in
and i want to thank all those including
the bavarian authorities
who have allowed us
and the very severe restrictions in
terms of numbers
i apologize especially to the many
journalists who would normally be in
attendance in physical attendance that
of course was
not possible
so
before i
start with the program
let me make one remark under normal
circumstances we would be distributing
in the hallways etc the so-called
security times a special
edition of an english
language newspaper produced by a good
friend of the munich security conference
deadlift prince i just want to say that
everybody who wants to read this can
download it
from our conference website
and we will seek to distribute some
copies
some physical call at the end of the
conference to those who wish to have one
now
after a fantastic opening day
of this conference yesterday
we have
a very important sequence of panels and
speakers ahead of us today i'm really
excited about this
uh we'll talk about the middle east the
indo-pacific
and certainly
as you would say in german as the rote
farden
the crisis
as annalina berber yesterday said the
russian crisis the russian crisis
but first
it is my honor my privilege
to start this day
on a very
extremely positive note
uh by pres preventing the munich
security's annual award the evald von
kleist award named
after the founder
of the munich security conference
this award honors personalities
and
or or organizations which have made
important contributions
to international stability and security
past recipients
include
helmut schmidt
john mccain
the united nations
henry kissinger and many others
under normal circumstances
municipalizator would have hosted i
think he would he would have loved to
host
a grand dinner
in his residence
in the midst of which we would have had
the award ceremony that is not possible
under pandemic circumstances
so like many other things this year is
different
and the moment for the award ceremony is
right now here
in
in the midst of our business meeting
i am privileged
to present the 2022
ewald frontlines award
to a man
who has been a physical
pillar of stability
for the transatlantic community
and for the transatlantic relationship
during
troubling times
and he's always been a true friend and
supporter of the munich security
conference i'm speaking of jens
stoltenberg the secretary general
of nato jens
my applause
secretary stoltenberg has served nato
with
great distinction now for eight years
and he is i'd like to note the second
secretary general of nato
to receive this award i'd like to
to ask javier zolana who was the first
recipient to just get up and
and show that he's in the room
[Applause]
[Music]
mr secretary general under
under your leadership with your steady
hand
you helped find compromise on so many
issues and provided a basis for unity
within the alliance under your
leadership
nato has
not just weathered troubled sometimes
troubled waters
but it has
consistently come out stronger
more united better prepared
for the immense challenge we're all
facing today
this weekend actually
and for those challenges that are likely
to confront us tomorrow
with your support the music security
conference has been among the small
circle of partners of nato
invited and entrusted with hosting
engagement formats in the margins of
nate of important nato meetings such as
nato summits
and we're grateful to you for these
opportunities
now i'd like to hand over
the floor to municipality
for his welcoming words
which will then be followed by laudatory
remarks offered by
the president of the commission of the
european union jose lafonderline
mr
minister president hermeneutic
[Applause]
[Music]
is
that
[Music]
be
ambassador ishinga take my seat please
yes come on here
secretary general dear jens ladies and
gentlemen
well the very reason
that
the union the european union was once
created is
that we wanted to put an end to old
european wars
and thus the world has been watching in
disbelief
as we face the largest buildup of troops
on european soil since the darkest days
of the cold war
because the events of these days could
reshape the entire international order
ukraine has just celebrated its 30 years
of independence
there's an entire generation of
ukrainians
born and bred in a free country
they are children of democracy
but now they are confronted on a daily
basis
with external aggression
and interference
some of them have lost relatives or
classmates in the donbass war
they are faced again with the prospect
of con conscription
to fight a war that they don't want but
that moscow might choose to impose on
them
this is what the kremlin's policies mean
in practice
to instill fear
and call it security demands
to deny 44 million ukrainians from
deciding freely
about their own future
to deny a free country's right
to independence and self-determination
and the consequences of this approach
matter well beyond ukraine
the kremlin is not only trying to
undermine the entire european security
architecture
the helsinki principles that have made
all european countries
safer
including russia
it is also violating the uan charter
with states that countries and eyesight
shall refrain from the threat and use of
force against the territorial integrity
or political independence of any state
and of citation
we cannot let this stand
we're facing a blatant attempt
to rewrite the rules of the
international order
one only has to read the recent
communique issued by russian and chinese
leaders
they seek a new area
as they say
to replace the existing international
rules
they prefer
the rule of the strongest
to the rule of law
intimidation instead of
self-determination
coercion instead of cooperation
we still hope
that peace will prevail and that
diplomacy
will take us there
and allow me to address how europe can
support this work
first we should be ready to respond
our european union with our
transatlantic partners we have been
preparing a robust
package of financial and economic
sanctions including on energy and
cutting-edge technology
if the kremlin strikes
we can impose high costs and severe
consequences on moscow's economic
interests
the kremlin stranger thinking which
comes straight out of a dark past
may cost russia a prosperous future
second is diversification
a strong european union
cannot be so reliant on an energy
supplier that threatens to start a war
on our continent
gazprom a russian state-owned company is
deliberately trying
to store and deliver as little as
possible
where prices and demand are skyrocketing
this is a very strange behavior for a
company
we must diversify both our suppliers and
our energy sources
and the work is already underway
we have reached out to our partners and
friends
across the globe
and today i can say
that even in case of full disruption of
gas supply of from russia
we are on the safe side for this winter
and in the medium and long term we're
doubling down on renewables
sun wind hydropower green hydrogen this
will increase europe's strategic
independence for energy
my third point is
supporting democracy in ukraine
for seven years now the russian
leadership has tried to destabilize
ukraine
hybrid war cyber attacks disinformation
you name it
yet
the country is now stronger than seven
years ago
because it has chosen the path of
democracy
and the friendship of other democracies
think again about the youth of ukraine
the post-soviet generation
they know that their democracy is not
perfect
but it is
and it is getting stronger year by year
and this is what makes us stand out from
autocracies
thriving democracies are the autocrats
greatest fear
because their propaganda fails when
citizens are empowered by the reporting
of independent media and the free
exchange of ideas
because free citizens speak truth to
power
because trust and confidence
are more sustainable than control and
coercion
and this is exactly why europe is
supporting ukraine's path to democracy
it makes ukraine a better place to live
for its people
and a better neighbor for both
the european union and russia
and my fourth and final point
is about unity
since the start of this kremlin-made
crisis the european union and the
transatlantic community
are fully aligned and united
we're supporting ukraine to withstand
the enormous pressure from moscow
when a russian government tried to
divide us over and over again
we have responded
with one voice
and one common
message and this has been possible
also thanks to you
dear jens
you always pushed us to focus on what we
have in common
you have shown that the european union
and nato stand side by side
not only because we share members and
allies
but because we share values
that is independence respect for human
rights
freedom
and democracy
the very values that are at stake in
this crisis
and this is why it makes me proud and
happy
to announce that you are this year's
kleist award winner
you have come a long way
to reach this high office
when you were young
you were the head of the young
socialists in norway
an organization that at the time was
certainly not known to be a strong
supporter of nato not at all
but yang yens used his charm and his
leadership
to turn the young norwegian socialists
around and support us believe it or not
as prime minister of norway
yens had to deal with russia on a
regular basis actually by then
lavrov was already being lavrov and yet
you managed with skill
to resolve a decades-long territorial
dispute in the barren sea
dear jens
you have always been a man of dialogue
and a believer in the transatlantic bond
in almost 10 years at the helm of nato
you always carried the flame
of this unique alliance
nobody worked harder than you
for the transatlantic alliance
you have pushed relentlessly to
strengthen our unity
and this is why no one deserves this
year's cleist award more than you
congratulations dear jens
[Applause]
thank you
thank you very much madam president
uh we are now
going to have the award ceremony so may
i invite you jens to join us here on the
podium
and
over there
just document
[Laughter]
can we
can we take a little distance and and
then take off the mask
like this
[Applause]
all right
thank you jens
so now you have the floor
congratulations
yes
it is
thank you so much uslove for those who
kind the words and
thank you also so much for our very
close cooperation over these years the
relationship and the cooperation between
nato and the european union has never
been closer and that's uh not least
because of your commitment to
bringing this relationship so close
together and uh and strengthening the
transatlantic bomb by working together
with nato and also many thanks to
minister president serdo for your warm
welcome here in munich and also for
informing me that you have danced with
the
president from the lion i have never had
the courage but now maybe
and many many thanks to you wolfgang for
uh
your outstanding leadership of the
munich security conference and for this
prestigious award i am really and
greatly honored and thank you so much
erwil von kleist championed the
transatlantic alliance
he saw the value
of europe and north america
standing together to keep us all safe
his message is as important today
these are dangerous days for europe
russia has relentlessly mass troops in
and around ukraine
in the biggest military buildup since
the cold war
we do not know what will happen but the
risk
for conflict is real
nato allies continue their strong
diplomatic efforts to find a political
solution
however despite moscow's claims
we have seen no sign of withdrawal or
de-escalation so far
on the contrary
russia's military buildup continues
we continue to monitor
very closely
we call on russia
to do what it says and withdraw its
forces from the borders of ukraine
this will be an
important first step
towards a peaceful solution
it is not too late for russia to change
course
to step back from the brink
stop preparing for war and start working
for a peaceful solution
nato remains ready to engage in the
substantive dialogue with moscow
to take meaningful reciprocal steps that
can improve security for all countries
in europe
and for russia too
we have made written proposals
to moscow
to reduce risks and increase
transparency of military activities
address
space and cyber threats and engage on
arms control
including
on nuclear weapons and missiles
this is a substantial agenda
where we believe it is possible to find
common ground
so i have invited russia and all nato
allies to a series of meetings of the
nato-russia council
and i reiterated my invitation in the
letter that has sent to minister lavrov
on thursday
the current crisis is about more than
ukraine
there is much at stake
relations between nato and russia
european and transatlantic security
and ultimately the question of how we
wish to organize
relations between states
moscow is attempting to roll back
history
and recreate
its spheres of influence
it wants to limit nato's right to
collect the defense
and demands that we should remove all
our forces and infrastructure from the
countries that join nato after the fall
of the valiant wall
but let me be clear
there is no first class nato members in
the west of the alliance
and second class nato members to the
east
we are all nato allies
and we stand as one
and we'll always do what is necessary to
protect and defend each other
moscow also wants to
deny sovereign countries the right to
choose their own path
and their own security arrangements
for ukraine
but also for other countries such as
finland and sweden
and for the first time
we now see beijing joining moscow in
calling on nato to stop admitting new
members
it is an attempt to control the faith of
free nations
to rewrite the international rulebook
and impose their own authoritarian
models of governance
the current crisis
demonstrates the importance of the
transatlantic relationship for european
security
two world wars and the cold war has
taught us that there is no real security
in europe without a strong transatlantic
bomb
standing together in nato
europe and america will continue to keep
the peace and protect our democratic way
of life
as we have done for more than 70 years
nato is a defensive alliance we are not
threatening russia or anyone else
but we will take all necessary measures
to protect and defend all allies
this is why
in response to russia's pattern of
aggressive actions
we have been strengthening our detents
and defense across the alliance
to avoid any miscalculation or
misunderstanding about our ironclad
commitment
to defend each other
so if kremlin's aim
is to have less nato on its borders
it will only get more nato
and if it wants to divide nato it will
only get an even more united alliance
over the last years our security
environment has fundamentally changed
for the worse
peace cannot be taken for granted
freedom and democracy are contested
and strategic competition is on the rise
this is a new normal
and we must be prepared
and do everything we can to keep the
bond between america
and europe as strong as ever
after the experience of horrors or war
ayerval von kleist knew that europe and
america
together was the guarantee of lasting
peace
it still is today
by standing together we can and will
keep our people safe
protect our core values and principles
and uphold the rules-based international
order
thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much uh jens mr secretary
general
um
thank both of you uh
madam madam president
maybe this is better without
and you
mr secretary general for your
presentations
we've had a long stand standing
tradition at the munich security
conference that at the main event on
saturday morning the first question
always goes to francois heisber of
france
now francois
franco has informed me i think late last
night that he is actually tested
positive he was already in munich so
he's now somewhere in quarantine i guess
but he has sent me overnight
the question he had intended to ask by
raising his arm as the first one so i
this is my privilege now
to present his question as the first one
so francois i'm sure you're listening
the question is
is is actually asked
of
the president of the eu commission but i
think it's also a question that you
would want to respond to and i quote
are the european union and its member
states
ready
to jointly and severally together and
separately express their support
of a possible candidacy of any of the
european union's members to join the
atlantic alliance
for those who are not so familiar with
this this is a question about for
example finland a question for example
of sweden
um four months so madam president
first of all
yeah first of all
it should work just you should yeah
i think it's a very good sign dear jens
that ambassador ishinger
um
asked this question to the european
union
um president of the commission so um
it's not to me for me to
to judge about uh internal issues of
nato but of course i'm very willing uh
to answer this because indeed
um i've been watching my time as the
five years as defense minister being of
course in the alliance of nato
how very close the cooperation for
example with sweden and finland already
is of nato first and foremost is it is
the decision of the people of sweden and
finland what they want to do and which
kind of
alliance or partnerships they um prefer
but then
of course i've witnessed that there is a
long-standing excellent cooperation
between nato and those members of the
european union many missions they are
part participating in
joint capabilities were developing
so
you are always of course
emphasizing rightly so that there is an
open door policy in nato and therefore
now after having spoken for the members
of the european union i throw the ball
to unions to speak about nato itself
thank you so much ursula and uh i think
the fact that we can answer this
question together just demonstrates how
closely the relationship is between the
european union and nato and also between
uh usra and uh and me
as you said usually the thing is that it
is enshrined in nato's uh founding
treaty the washington street in article
10 that we have an open door that
european countries can join the nation
but this is and and the enlargement of
nato of the last decades has been a
great success
it has helped to spread democracy
freedom throughout europe and actually
pave the way for further eu enlargement
uh demonstrating how closely we work
together
um so
in that sense
nato's open door has been a success and
nato store remains open
the
important message is that it is for
individual countries in europe to decide
whether they aspire for membership they
want to belong to nato or they do not
want to belong to nato that's for them
to decide therefore we respect those
allies on the sort of those countries
that inspire membership we sit down and
we look into how can we help them with
reform so they meet the nato standard
standards and can join at some stage
but we also respect if they decide not
to apply so for instance when finland
and sweden have decided that they are
not applying for membership of course we
respect also that decision
i will not speculate about the
likelihood of finland and sweden uh
changing their mind i think that's very
much for it is it is it is for finland
and sweden to decide that's the main
point and as a norwegian i will be very
careful giving advice to swedes and
finns so
so
we trust the swedes and the finns they
decide as long as they decide to stay
outside we are very happy to have very
close cooperation
with both countries
great thank you very much to both of you
now
those of you who wish to ask a question
there are two ways of doing that first
the heisbor way by just waving
and making yourself known to me
or by using the electronic manner i have
a tablet here
which would show me questions that are
being typed
electronically so use the opportunity
who which who wishes to raise the first
question i think this is not only touchy
if i if i'm not mistaken natalie
microphone is coming
question to president vanderlian um
as your second key word you mentioned
diversification and it was a word that
had disappeared from the european
lexicon for a while
energy security diversification had
really not been talked about for quite
some time
how do you square the circle if there is
a circle to be squared between the
return of energy security to the debate
through diversification and your
landmark uh sort of
your trademark for for this commission
which of course is the european green
deal
thank you very much i am of course focus
um
as your your question indicate is
located on um our dependency first of
all on russian gas
just to give you figures
round about 24
overall in the energy mix of the
european union
is gas
we import 90 of this gas
and 40
of this import is russian gas so quite a
high dependency
it's very different from member state to
member state
for example as france is relying on
nuclear energy they are not at all
dependent on russian gas other member
states for example italy or germany have
a more intense
dependency on russian gas
what we've seen over the last six months
is that gasprom
has delivered always at the lowest level
they have to deliver by contract they
have contracts that say pay or deliver
so often they've chosen the payment
instead of to deliver
a gas and the storage is of gas prom in
our storages is a 10 years low
this year
and this at the time as i said where we
have skyrocketing prices and demand it's
a strange behavior of a company who
normally would maximize their profits by
delivering more and storing better for
winter to come
therefore
we have decided to do everything
possible to get rid of this dependency
and we've reached out to our friends who
are suppliers of lng gas
first and foremost the united states
that really helped a lot also the
reaching reach out globally but also to
other suppliers of lng
actually it helps us that we have done
our homework since 2014 the annexation
crimea because we've built an lng
terminals and more important we have now
a network of pipelines and electricity
interconnectors
throughout europe so that wherever you
have the gas you can display it all over
the european union
partially also a reverse flow for
example to ukraine to support ukraine
with the energy demands
and now to the second part
of your question for the moment being we
would be able to replace
the russian gas with lng deliveries that
we get from our friends all over the
world and we are supported
actually also by buyers like japan or
south korea
who are willing to swap contract with us
so that the ships with the
lng gas are de-rooted to the european
union
now lng gas remains fossil fuel without
any question
the advantage is
that the infrastructure that we use with
the lng or any kind of gas
is
over time suitable and fit for purpose
for green hydrogen
and therefore now our work goes and we
had yesterday the eu africa summit
to goes into looking towards the global
south
they have an abundance sun and wind and
hydropower
they need the infrastructure
but there to have over time the
development of a solid green hydrogen
infrastructure using the pipelines we do
have already in place
and thus giving a complete different a
business case to the global south our
african friends for example of course
green hydrogen for the european union
too and i can only say these renewable
energies they are clean and therefore
good for the planet but they are also
home grown and therefore good for our
independence
thank you madam president i see a couple
of more questions before i go to you
let me use my privilege of
being the moderator here to
turn to jen stoltenberg again
and you will be leaving nato uh toward
the end of this year as i understand
and i want to remind you that as the
future head
of the norwegian central bank
like all the other recipients of the
kleist award you will have a standing
invitation to the munich security
conference it's one of the reasons why
javier is always here each year and i
hope you'll you'll be with us again
here's my my question
eight years ago in 2014
nato decided
to
define
as as a as a collective goal this famous
two percent goal
let's assume
the worst case namely that we're going
to have some degree of military
confrontation in coming days weeks
months
as you
prepare your own departure from nato in
coming months would you think that the
two percent objective goal
which was a goal for 2024
10 year goal
is going to be good enough or is nato
going to have to say under these
circumstances we're actually going to
have to
you know take it up another notch
question
well i think what happens now just
underlines
how important it was back in 2014 to
make the decision to go to two percent
and then i think we should deliver on
that first and then
uh we can discuss the next step after
that uh because what has happened uh
because what has happened is that
is that before 2014 uh defense budgets
were going down across europe and uh and
canada in almost all allied countries uh
year by year uh because after the end of
the cold war european countries uh
thought that they could spend less on
the defense and i i was part of that
myself i was prime minister and minister
finance in norway and for many years we
cut defence spending but then
after the illegal annexation of crimea
and what happened in europe in 2014
things changed and the good thing is
that
all allies actually realized that we
need to do something different and the
most important different thing
thing we had to do was to invest more
and since 2014 all allies in europe and
canada have increased defence spending
every year
and they have in total added 270 billion
extra for defence
and of course this is not only about
money but it's about capabilities
because with this money you can buy
drones and planes and battle tanks and
readiness and exercises and a lot of
important stuff
the main reason to do this is not to
provoke the war but it's to prevent the
war and i think and exactly what is
happening now
demonstrate that our strength and the
fact that we can deploy more troops at
higher readiness to the eastern part of
alliance
is a way to send a very clear message to
moscow that we are there to protect and
defend all allies an attack on one will
be regarded as attack on all
uh that's exactly the best way to
prevent any armed attack on any nato
allies so so uh
well it just
demonstrates that what uh
the the decision makers in 2014 decided
they were
wise and forward-looking and uh
former secretary general arnold
schwarzenegger here in the audience and
he was responsible then
uh and uh and many others have been part
of that big transformation of nato
thank you thank you very much now i
think the first
raised hand i saw was dr chipman of
double i double s
john
yes to uh secretary general uh jen
stoltenberg in the last seven or eight
years as the double iws has
transparently recognized in our famous
uh volume the military balance the
russians have massively uh modernized
their conventional armed forces
introduced lots of technologies in a
much more
professional army but in that time as
well
they have been modernizing uh their
nuclear weapons um adding more
capabilities change their uh doctrine
and only in the next few days we might
see the formal change of the belarus
constitution that would permit the
stationing of nuclear weapons in belarus
against that background what would you
judge to be the first two or three
priorities of the nato nuclear planning
group and what place would uh nuclear
strategy have in nato's new uh strategic
concept and a caveat for the president
of the european commission the double
iws which is now happy to have a europe
office in berlin is working on the
subject of green uh defense and i wonder
uh as the president of a geopolitical
commission what collaboration we would
be able to have with the european
commission to ensure that militaries
continue to green uh their operations
while maintaining their effectiveness
thank you
well i think you're absolutely right
that what we have seen over the last
years is that russia has invested
heavily in modernizing their nuclear
capabilities they have changed their
nuclear doctrines and they have actually
lowered the threshold for use of nuclear
weapons in armed conflict this is
something of course we are taking very
seriously and therefore i think it's
important that we
maintain our nato nuclear deterrent that
to make sure that we keep it safe and
secure and effective
uh and uh also uh i think it also
demonstrates that what we are in favor
of is balanced reciprocal verifiable
arms control also when it comes to
nuclear weapons but we are not in favor
of unilateral nuclear disarmament from
the nato side
nato's goal is a world without nuclear
weapons but the world where we get rid
of our nuclear weapons
and that china russia north korea iran
and so on they keep their weapons
that's not a safer world that's a more
dangerous world
so
yes we believe in the world without
nuclear weapons but the only way to get
there
is through very viable balanced uh arms
control and that's exactly what nato is
working for
madam yes thank you um so john um i
think whatever if you look at the
defense sector whatever is rolling
flying or swimming
needs energy
energy is the core
of any kind of european green deal or
global green deal to fight climate
change and therefore i was
the other answer already reflecting over
changing our posture of
energy supply
and whatever goes for fighter jets as
well as any kind of airplanes goes for
cars or armored vehicles you name it
that you have to change the approach of
the energy you use not the dirty carbon
heavy fossil fuel energies but the
renewables clean ones and for example
the prospect of hydrogen is a highly
interesting
one to work with and therefore there is
quite a lot of music in it it is a
fascinating business case because for us
is important we know we have to fight
climate change otherwise we're all
doomed and therefore if we invest in the
innovation if we invest in clean energy
if we invest in a different way to
produce and to consume
we will be the innovators who export
then these technologies it's a big topic
of innovation and therefore it is for us
not only something which is so important
for the climate itself but it's a very
clear business case it's our new growth
strategy
all right i've seen a few raised hands
the one i
know
who raises and is stefan cornelius
of suit deutsche zeitung so stefan
please
thank you it's a question to uh the
president of the commission of of on the
line why uh since you're displaying
unity between the eu and nato and the
stage why did the eu
not call for an earlier meeting on uh
the heads of states there was now a
special summit in the lines of the uh
african union meeting just a few hours
ago
but this crisis is boiling for i don't
know two months at least
and we haven't seen heads of states
unifying and at least finding some
coherent strategy on sort of the
reaction of the day after
so how are we working
since many many weeks
six to eight weeks now we are preparing
for this looming crisis which is
unfortunately since then always going in
the wrong direction with a massive
buildup of troops that has not stopped
and of course there is a very strong
alignment between the european union the
united states the united kingdom canada
on a regular basis we have by now in the
last weeks once or twice a week of etc
or yesterday evening for example a
telephone call
together um the the countries joe biden
justin trudeau boris johnson some of our
leaders like olaf schultz emmanuel
macron mario draghi you were of course
yesterday also you are on a regular
basis in these sessions
this is to align on a regular basis on
all the necessary steps we have to take
what are these steps
the commission has developed a robust
and comprehensive package together with
the united states uk and canada of
financial sanctions
that in case that russia
strikes we will limit the access to the
financial markets for russian for the
russian economy and export controls
that will
stop the possibility for russia to
modernize and diversify its economy
and we have a lot of high-tech
goods
where we have a global dominance and
that are absolutely necessary for russia
and cannot be replaced easily
we also prepare in this group for
example
what is the state of cyber attack
robustness and resilience we have within
our system but also supporting ukraine
we are preparing for potential refugees
coming we are preparing on all sorts of
fields i've been uh referring to the
energy field so there's a constant
alignment let's say behind the scene
the european council
will be called
within hours if it is necessary to take
a political decision in case that russia
uh is striking or is beginning a war in
the uh ukraine
but
all the preparatory work so the
alignment between all these 27 member
states the european union and
the other friends and allies goes on
since weeks and weeks and weeks and
that's where the core of the work is
that's where the bulk of the results is
coming from now
thank you very much we have uh less than
five minutes to go
i have one question on my tablet here
which is addressed to secretary general
of nato comes from clemence vergine who
is a journalist with divelt german
newspaper this goes to mr stoltenberg
i'm quoting how can the west counter
in the realm of informational measures
what seems to be russian false flag
operations in donbass
to expose what they do and that's
exactly what we have done
because we have been very open
transparent on the information we have
received intelligence and other types of
information
both about the russian military buildup
and it is as usual said this actually
started uh uh
several months ago this fall and we all
did then warned both that we saw a
buildup going taking place but also of
the plans of further building up and
what we predicted back then has actually
happened
uh second we've also been very
transparent on
the attempts by russia to create a
pretext
to create a situation that they will use
as an excuse for attacking
ukraine and we have seen some attempts
we have seen some some
very dangerous situations and also what
we see taking place now just adds to
that picture
of a concern that they are trying to
create a pretext
for an invasion but the reason why we
have been so transparent uh
the united states other allies and nato
is that and we believe that when we
expose this these plans
we make it harder for them uh to do what
they're planning to do
so so the
reason to expose is to prevent
that from happen that they are planning
to do
we are extremely concerned because we
see that they continue they continue to
build up they continue to prepare
and we have never in europe seen since
the end of the cold war such a large
concentration of combat ready troops uh
and of course that sends a very very
common or dangerous signal to all of us
let me add one more thing wolfgang and
that is that
you know what they do in russia now is
partly to master troops
but they have also put forward
claims demands not only to ukraine but
also to nato
they have demanded that we should leave
our
enshrined commitment to open door
and they have demanded that we should
remove all nato troops and forces from
almost half of the member states
and there and and then they have said
that if we don't meet those demands
they have repeatedly said
there will be what they call military
technical consequences
so the danger is now the combination of
this massive military buildup with the
very threatening rhetoric
putting forward demands they know we
cannot meet and say if we don't meet
them they will be military consequences
so this is a
a step change this is a new normal that
you have a russia which is
openly contesting core values for
european security and then demonstrating
their will to use force or the threat of
force
to get
their will
and that's the reason why it is so
extremely important that we are united
europe and north america
worked closely with the european union
but also that we actually have
demonstrated our commitment with
increased military presence in eastern
part of the arts
thank you jens i think we have
a minute left i saw a question from the
very back of the room if you can
turn this into a very quick question and
if we can get a very quick response then
we're still good
uh robin
this is robin niblet i didn't recognize
your face so robin right at the back uh
where britain is at the moment sometimes
any case robin um i wanted to ask a
question that maybe mirrors what
francois uzberg asked at the beginning
which was interesting he asked a
question to us underlying whether she
would support nato enlargement i suppose
i'd flip the question and say is this
not a time to be talking about
accelerating ukrainian membership of the
eu
and as we have the two leaders of these
two institutions side by side one of the
biggest threats obviously to
russia's interest ukraine will be a much
closer relationship with the european
union so
um secretary general uh of nato would
you support uh
an acceleration of the process of uh
negotiation for enlargement to ukraine
to the european union
it's not for me to decide i actually
tried to convince no norwegians to join
uh eu and i didn't succeed so
i think i should be very careful giving
advice to others uh but uh but but the
principle still applies
that of course it is for individual
countries in europe to decide whether
they want to belong to nato uh or they
want to belong to eu and then there is
for the members of nato to decide
whether they uh can join our alliance
and then for the members of eu to decide
whether they can join eu that's the
that's the principle and that is what is
contested now
because they're absolutely possible to
have different views so whether
nato or the eu should have
this or that new member but this is not
the issue the issues whether that is a
decision to be made by those individual
countries and the members of the
organizations or whether russia has a
veto to decide what neighbors can do or
not to that's to re-establish spheres of
influence we don't believe in that we
don't believe in in going back in
history really we believe in free
independent nations making their own
free democratic choices
thank you very much mr secretary general
it's reassuring to me and i'm sure to
many in the room to see how well nato
and the european union
work hand in hand
let me
propose that we offer a round of
applause to our two speakers
and
and of course most importantly to
congratulate jen stoltenberg again on on
receiving the award
ladies and gentlemen please don't leave
the room because with within literally
seconds or a minute at maximum we're
going to have chancellor
schultz
coming in and continuing the program so
stay put if you could thank you very
much
ladies and gentlemen please remain
seated as the program will continue
momentarily
oh